[Music]
maybe if we gave Peter a really
wonderful Christmas gift it would make
him happy
what kind of present something special
he will never forget
what about someone special
what or the year school has talked about
one person more than any other a
legendary hero who has saved countless
lives we could give him the quilt as a
present
[Music]
yeah can I help you
yes we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon we're looking for the
legendary Kevin Bacon
the voice is smaller mousey I think
maybe he didn't hear you he
has probably got great ears I'm sorry
guys
I can't help
[Music]
you you think you can toss me over the
gate a few
[Music]
what are you doing tossing you over the
gates I didn't mean right that second I
meant after I was ready
I wasn't even done talking tossed you
over the gate don't touch over the gate
make up your mind
[Music]
wow
I want this funny man
don't just take stuff
[Music]
but I guess that's what it's here for
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
it would make him happy
[Music]
something special he will never forget
what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon
I think maybe he didn't hear you
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present
[Music]
I'm through
it Twas the Night Before Christmas on a
set lit so bright a director was
planning an awesome day like to make a
Marvel special with some holiday fun
that man was none other than director
James Gunn
it is the very first thing ever
conceived from Marvel Studios for Disney
plus it's a fantastic story vomited from
the brain of a Mad genius action on the
set of volume 2 James Gunn said we
should do a holiday special
Merry Christmas
we all had a laugh we thought that would
be great and then they wrote it like
three days
[Music]
holiday special it's like awesome this
has been a real joyful shoot because I
get to work with a lot of people I
really loved
I think audiences are really going to be
excited it's probably going to be played
every year for the rest of our lives
Kevin Bacon you're coming with us that's
a Christmas present
for Christmas Time Is Here
[Music]